hey guys this is andrew from
tradingsensors.com so i'm a professional
trader and i've been working for several
big investment banks like hsbc or
commerce bank and i've just started to
make youtube videos
uh because i want to pass the knowledge
guys i see that a lot of you
have some interest now into investing
into the stock market
but you don't know exactly what
technique to use and
who you can trust so i'm here guys to
talk about my experience and show you
what
i like to use all the different
techniques that i use at work and that
work for
me so today i want to talk about all the
penny stocks guys
that went very high this recent days
one of them is clvs so let's get into it
[Music]
so guys uh for those who watched my
previous videos uh you could see that
i've already spoken about that stock
clvs and that i was seeing a very nice
potential
so basically the way i do this i
uh i'm hanging out guys on twitter on
wall street bets you know and i have all
these guys you know that give you
they talk about gme they talk about amc
uh and they give then give you uh like
the different potential targets so then
i'm gonna use my techniques and i'm
gonna check if the targets are for me
nice or not so for example on twitter
you know you have like so many guys you
know
that just talk about like the different
stocks they would buy like uh
plc dds i'm gonna check all of them one
by one and i'm gonna tell you if yes or
no for me it's uh
buying uh there is a buying signal or
not
so the first thing i do is that i just
check the market capitalization and the
short interest
because when the market capitalization
is low
it means that if all these guys
associate together which they like to do
they can have a strong impact on the
stock like for example if they do the
same thing on the bitcoin it won't have
a big impact because the market cap of
bitcoin is
around almost 1 trillion us dollar but
when you go to some penny stocks that
have around 1
or 2 billion usd market capitalization
with a strong short interest all right
who is shouting the staff
hedge funds that think that the
fundamentals are bad and that the stock
should go
lower and when you have a big short
interest which is true for all this list
guys i'm gonna check
all of them uh then it means that uh
potentially you can have a short squeeze
what happened on amc what happened on a
gme
and what will keep happening on the
stocks if there is enough buying
power that comes together in the game
all right
so first clvs guys so the earnings you
can see are just going lower so this is
the reason why the hedge fund are
attacking the stock
this stock was worth 100 like three or
four years ago
and now it's like 12 times lower around
8.
so here we have a breakout already that
occurred around six so if you haven't
bought
six uh you can still uh it's a very nice
level to buy
i think that we won't see this level
again
we have uh overcome another resistance
that was like the highest level we had
we had here
i was talking about this in my previous
videos guys and this was actually on the
shorter time frame
you can check on the four hours time
frame it was the level that
we had this build up you can see guys we
had a descending triangle
here tag
and attack all right and it got broken
on the upside and
now we go higher so we might come back
maybe to 8
58 something like this i don't think
we're gonna go lower
now and we had this uh maximum here the
the
three most recent highs were around
eight and that's why this consideration
happened at this level
so right now what is happening guys we
are going higher the next resistance
level would be 15
and then 31 and then 100 all right guys
so it's a hot stock i can see there is a
lot of discussion about the stock in all
these forums you know i told you i'm on
reddit i'm on twitter
and i'm checking everything that is
happening here guys all right because
those guys they are they're actually
pushing the market in the direction they
choose so i'm not sure who is like
taking the decisions on this forums but
what i can tell you is that i went
through
the list of the shares they're talking
about and a lot of them look attractive
technically speaking all right
so i've just done this very quickly guys
uh nothing
else to say for now so i'm a buyer
around eight uh taking profits around 15
as even 17 for the first level
and i'm gonna do many more stocks i'm
gonna do them one by one so guys please
hit the like button and the subscribe
button so you're gonna be the first to
know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show i'll see you
guys